MALE SPEAKER: We can start.
So I have the pleasure
to introduce Alexandre,
who is coming all the way from
Germany next to the Mont Blanc.
So Alexandre is a pro mountain
and adventure photographer.
And so he has, I think, written
three books on photography.
And yeah, he has a past
doing computer science.
And yeah, Alexandre will
put on some of his work.
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: Cool.
Thanks very much.
So yeah, thank you for coming.
My name is Alexandre
Buisse, as you cannot see
because it's in very dark
red just above Photos from
the Edge.
And the talk is titled
Photos from the Edge.
And I do apologize
as promised for it.
I'm giving the same
talk in London in a week
and they chose the title for me.
So this is what I
used to be doing.
Yeah, OK, there's
kind of a delay there.
Up until about two and a half
years ago, something like that.
And I managed to get out.
And this is what I do now.
And there is a sizable delay.
There you go.
Yeah, so this is now the
kind of stuff that I'm doing
and I'm having a
lot more fun doing.
For instance, hanging
on a fixed line
300 meters up the [INAUDIBLE]
in Verdon shooting people
rock climbing or
climbing myself.
And this is going
to get annoying.
There you go.
Rock climbing myself.
So this is in Patagonia.
And that's one of the big things
about the career I'm doing
is that I'm shooting
people climbing,
but I also have to climb
myself and ski myself
and to paraglide in [INAUDIBLE].
Well most all of those
sports, I have to do myself.
And this is another
kind of adventure
that I'm doing, kind of
combining it altogether.
Climbing up, skiing a bit
down, and then flying down.
And so I'm trying to have as
many adventures as possible.
This was, for instance,
paragliding off
the summit of Dent de Crolles.
We were trying for Mont Blanc,
but the winds were too high
on the summit of Mont Blanc.
Yeah, it's pretty
hardcore climbing gear.
I won't get too
technical in this talk.
I wasn't quite sure what
you guys were expecting.
So I'm not going to be giving
maybe specific photography
advice.
But I'm more talking about
what the lifestyle is like
and what the shoots are like.
But yeah, this is what
happens to my camera
on a fairly frequent basis.
And my insurance
company really hated me.
There we go.
So that's, of course, the most
beautiful place in the world.
And it's so much
better in Switzerland.
This is, of course, Germany
with-- so Mont Blanc is--
I wonder if I can
actually point.
But Mont Blanc is very close.
I actually shot that in a
series of panoramic pictures
of about 12 different
images that I
shot while flying down
from Vallee Blanche.
And this is why I am
lucky enough to live.
And so it's great
because Germany
is a big hub for all the sports
people, all mountaineers.
So I can find very easily
athletes to go shoot.
And I can very easily
go on adventures myself.
And the access that
you get in Germany's
unbelievable, because
you have a couple
of lifts that get
you pretty high up.
That get you up here
and then another one
gets you almost at the same
altitude on the [INAUDIBLE]
side.
So I can wake up in
my bed at 8:00 AM,
go take the first [INAUDIBLE],
have a full on adventure
climbing or skiing or flying,
and then be back down in time
to have some beer.
And I have, as Benoit said,
I've written three books so far.
So the first two, the second
one is actually an ebook.
But the first two were
published a couple of years
ago, 2011 mostly.
And they are dealing
with the technical side
of taking pictures in mountains.
And the third one was published
just a couple of months
ago in the last October.
I'm pleased to say
that it's actually--
the first print
run is exhausted.
So it sold really well.
I actually have a
copy here that you're
welcome to take a
look afterwards.
And I'm going to leave
it with Benoit anyway,
so you can have him.
And this is new.
I haven't talked to anybody
but you so far about it.
It's coming soon and
it's a book for geeks.
It's an ebook actually, and it's
about all the boring-ish things
that you have to do
with digital photography
and all dealing with
fonts and editing
and all that sort of
thing coming out soon.
All right.
So the way I think
this is going to work
is I'm going to walk you through
a couple of my recent shoots
and kind of talk about
what the clients wanted
me to do with the images,
what changes I had,
and what kind of images
I managed to produce
and the stories behind them.
And I'll try to
about 15, 20 minutes
for questions at the end.
But please feel
free to interrupt me
if you have anything
that you want to know.
So the first one is
on the Eigernordwand
and it was last August.
And what happened is
that this guy, this guy.
Yeah, this guy.
He's called Calum
Muskett, he's not even 20,
and he's an extremely talented
rock climber and alpinist
he's studying to be
a mountain guide.
And I haven't actually met him
but I knew he was in the Alps,
so I just sent him an
email saying basically,
if you're going to
climb something cool
and you want pictures
of it, let me know
and I'd be happy to take it on.
And I didn't hear
anything and then
I have plans to go climbing in
Germany and do whatever I do.
And then I got an email
from this guy saying,
I'm going to be
with Dave MacLeod.
We're in Grindelwald right now.
We are going to try to
climb Paciencia in two days.
You're welcome to
come if you want.
And Paciencia is currently
the hardest shoot
on the north face of the Eiger.
It has an 8a crux
pitch and it's just
ridiculously long and
involved and it has only
been climbed twice.
So I said sure,
and I came along.
And what you need to
know about the Eiger,
beside that it's a very
big, very scary mountain,
is that there is a
train that actually
goes to-- I mean, it
goes to Jungfraujoch,
which is further away.
But it goes through
the north face.
And so this is not
quite the north face.
This is the north face that's
kind of a small buttress.
But you have about a third
of the way of the north face
window into the railway, and
that's called the Stollenloch.
And what people can do often
is get dropped off by the train
and then exit.
And you just keep
the bottom third
of the face, which is dangerous,
loose, and not very interesting
because it's low angle.
And that's also where
the route starts.
So we're hoping to do that.
But it turns out we're not
Swiss, because I'm French
and those guys are British.
And so the railway
wouldn't let us,
because you have to be
Swiss to be let out.
It's amazing.
So we had to climb
from the bottom.
And those guys made two
carries up to the bivi site,
to the Stollenloch.
So they were fairly light.
But add two pro cameras, two
big lenses, my entire bivi
kit because I was
going to sleep there,
and then 17 meters of
rope that I could ascend.
So it's a pretty
sizable backpack.
And that's the kind of
terrain that we were on.
So it's not ridiculously hard.
Like, we're not roped up
because you can't really
put protection in.
And those guys are not
even in climbing boots.
But it's still steep, loose,
and dangerous, basically.
And what happened
shortly after I
took this picture is
that I broke a hand hold.
And I started pitching
back and managed
to catch myself at
the last second.
I kind of saw my life
flash in front of my eyes.
And those guys had to come
down and throw me a rope
and help me and take my backpack
because I was too scared
to actually keep going.
But anyway, we got
to the Stollenloch,
into the bivi site.
So that's an interesting point,
I think, with this picture.
Because it is not
a good picture.
It is at best a
passable picture.
But it tells a story.
And it kind of, if you
start from the first picture
of the guy in the train
and you go all the way
to the amazing
picture, hopefully,
that I capture at the end,
you can get a complete story
of what it's like to actually
climb this thing instead
of just seeing the amazing
picture and saying, yeah, cool.
And then not having any
idea what's actually
involved in climbing
something that big.
So I have to build
a story, and I
have to also try to capture
all those moments that are not
visually that interesting,
but that help build the story.
And that's going up fixed
lines with a lot of equipment.
And then, of course,
you try your best
to make it slightly
less passable
or a slightly better picture
by playing with focus
and foregrounds and
stuff like that.
And it's not a picture that's
designed to stand by itself,
but it helps move the
story along, hopefully.
So yeah, I had spent
all that time and effort
and nearly died
trying to get there
to have the pictures
of those guys climbing
with amazing backdrop,
crazily exposed.
And of course we get there and
they finally start climbing.
And the fog rolls in.
You have to roll with it.
And in cases like
that, the route
that they're climbing, because
they're actually climbing it
for real and I'm just
along for the ride.
So I can't ask them to wait
half an hour for the fog
to dissipate or do that again.
You can't do that.
So you have to make do
with the best you have
and kind of fool with it.
In that case, I
think, I hope that it
adds an atmospheric effect.
And anyway, didn't
really have any choice.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: How did
you get above them?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE:
So on this route,
you have-- so those are
the first hard pitches,
and they're 7c pitches.
And they are fixed lines already
in place from other teams
that are walking on the
route just to the side of it.
So it was very
lucky in that sense.
Otherwise, what I would do is
that, on really hard routes
like that, they usually
rehearse the moves.
So they would climb
it a first time
and then carry my
rope behind them.
And they wouldn't manage to
actually climb it in one go.
They would have to
rest in between.
Then they would fix my
rope and I would go up.
And then I would
shoot them from above
while they're actually
going for the lead.
And that's what happened
on the 8a pitch.
AUDIENCE: But it means
technically you're
doing exactly the
same that they do.
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: No, because
I cannot climb that hard,
especially with
cameras and stuff.
So when they are climbing
super hard routes like that,
super hard pitches
like that, I'm just
jogging on a fixed rope.
I'm ascending a
rope, thankfully.
So yeah, that's another
example of this image,
this atmospheric
image what the fog.
And that's another thing, that
you try sometimes to focus.
If you can't have the wide angle
picture with the crazy exposure
and crazy landscape
above, then you kind of
try to zoom in and
see, try to express
what it takes to
climb at this level.
And I think this is where
facial expressions are key,
because you can actually
convey how steep a bowl is.
This is actually overhanging
by like 20 degrees,
but you wouldn't know it.
And the holds are
always tiny, and you're
used to seeing tiny holds, so
it really doesn't bring much.
But if you see somebody
making crazy grimace
and then really
showing in his face
how hard it is to
climb, then hopefully
that's how you convey the
message to the viewer.
And I think personally that
this image works well for that.
Right.
And that's coming up.
There you go.
So that's another example.
You won't get that picture
as cover of the catalogue
or as cover of the magazine.
But this is an important
picture nonetheless,
because it tells the story of
you have to spend nights there,
and you have to carry
all your stuff there,
and you have equipment
everywhere, and you're biviing,
it's cold.
But they're still smiling.
And that's also
something that, you know,
they were always
having fun and I
was trying to convey
that through my pictures.
And again, another
picture that hopefully
helps tell the story of this
is super, super steep and this
is hard work getting up there.
Even though on its own
it's not a great picture.
And so on this one,
things start to get real.
There you go.
It's a picture I'm showing
here but I didn't even
show it to the client,
but just to give
an idea of what it's like.
And you have gear everywhere,
equipment everywhere, ropes
kind of in knots everywhere.
But you spent all that time
and energy getting there.
And that's when
it really starts.
AUDIENCE: How much of this
was free climbed and how much
wasn't?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: Oh,
they free climbed 100%.
So that's the whole point.
It took eight years for
this route to be free
climbed the first
time by Ueli Steck.
He's the one who opened it.
So in that case, they had
rehearsed the pitch-- that's
the 8a pitch, the crux
pitch I had come to shoot.
And I was hanging
on my fixed line.
And then here, Dave
is not quite in.
He's putting a route there.
So I can't actually
quite see his feet.
And there's a rule in
climbing photography
that you have to
see the eyes and you
have to see both hands and both
feet for the picture to work.
So in that sense, the
picture doesn't really
work because you
can't see his feet.
But you can still see his face.
And then you have
this whole thing
going on with the
background out of focus.
And the background that
takes so much of the image.
And so at this stage
I couldn't really
shoot a typical classical
good climbing image.
So what I did was
just try to experiment
with different compositions
and to tell a different story
than just this is hard.
It's up to you whether
that actually worked.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you said imagine
the rules [INAUDIBLE].
I wonder is there
a rule for in which
phase of the move you shoot.
Like everything attached
or just before they move?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: It
completely depends.
And that's why actually
being a climber yourself
is going to help
greatly, because you'll
be able to anticipate
what's going on.
No, I don't think
there's a rule.
Usually if you can show
movement, it's much better.
But it's often you will get
better suggestion of movement
if somebody's, for
instance, you can
see that he's readying to move.
And that he's in
a position where
he's going to jump rather than
if he's actually mid-jump,
sometimes it doesn't
actually look that good.
But I'm not aware, at least,
of any rule about that.
So yeah.
Now we're getting to the image
that I had come to shoot.
And here, this one
is almost there.
And that's Calum at the
top of the 8a pitch.
And you can see two
hands, two feet, the eyes.
You can get a small
idea of the angle.
And then you have something
really interesting.
You don't even see Dave because
he's belaying below the roof.
But you can see the rope because
I'm shooting very wide angle,
it gives the impression that
the rope goes on forever.
And that's a 50
meter pitch already.
And then you can kind of
see that the wall just
keeps on going.
So I kind of really like this
picture, but this one-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: So for this one you
are just pushing with your feet
out from the wall?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: Yeah.
I'm going to mention that.
Yeah, there you go.
This looks really ugly.
I'm going to talk about that
just now, because here this
is for me the picture
from the shoot.
And the clients agree.
And for that actual picture,
I'm very far away from the wall,
as you can see.
And this is, of course,
sometimes people
bring ladders to
push themselves away.
Obviously, that
wasn't an option here.
So what happened is that
this is actually crazy
overhanging, maybe 25 degrees.
My rope was anchored at the top.
And then I was
kicked through one
of the quickdraws on the route.
The one just above the one
where he's climbing right now.
And that meant that, of
course, when Dave came,
he had to use that quickdraw
and keep on climbing.
So I had to let go of it.
And when I let go, I just
took a huge pendulum.
And when I was out five or six
meters at the apex, I shot.
And then what happened
is that I have the blow
back of the pendulum, and I'm
just starting to slam back,
and I'm slamming
back into Dave, who's
climbing this super hard route.
So I was like that trying
to be as thin as possible.
And I just barely grazed
him and then went back
from the pendulum and
did that a couple times.
AUDIENCE: In that case, do
you look on the display?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: No.
No, I just never
look on the display.
I look on the display
when I'm back home.
And that's also super important
as a climbing photographer
is to never disturb
the climbers,
because they trust me
not to bother them,
not to be a presence
that they will
have to spend time and energy.
I mean, the worst
thing I could possibly
do beside injure them
would be to make them fall,
especially when they're
climbing something that hard.
Sometimes, you have to
let go of the picture.
You have to not
take a picture so
that you won't be in the way.
AUDIENCE: Tell us a little
bit about the technical piece
about this particular
photograph site.
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: As in--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: So
this is wide angle.
I like to shoot very wide.
That's a Nikon D100 and
the lens is a 1635 F4,
which is my go to lens
because it's fairly light.
And then you can see
everything is in focus.
So I was actually,
I think, at F11.
And pre-focused at
about two meters
so that I don't even
have to go to focus.
And I'm always shooting
in aperture priority.
So in that case,
I don't even have
to put the camera
to my eye really.
I mean, I usually
try to, but sometimes
there's too much
going on for me to.
So I just get an idea of where
I'm framing and just shooting.
And I don't fiddle
with the settings ever.
AUDIENCE: How far
are you from him?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: I
think, yeah, something
like five or six
meters out of the wall.
AUDIENCE: So you focus at
two, two or thereabouts.
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: Yeah, because
with high bifocal distance
at F11, especially
at 16 millimeters,
everything will be in focus.
And sometimes, of course,
especially when I'm shooting
long, I really tried to
have shallow depth of field
and shoot at F2.8 usually
to really separate,
create some separation.
But when I'm shooting
wide, usually it's
very rare that you
would try to get
shallow depth of
field shooting wide.
You try to get
everything in focus.
And after that picture,
shortly afterwards,
they took two more days to
climb and I abseilled down
and went through
the Stollenloch,
hitchhiked on the train,
and had a big rosti.
There you go.
So that was the first shoot.
The second one actually
happened just 10 days ago.
The story was, through some too
long to explain circumstances,
I met the editor from
"Sports Illustrated",
which is one of the biggest
magazines in the world.
In the States it's 3.5
million readership, I think.
And they usually are all
about the Superbowl yesterday
and the baseball and basketball
and that kind of thing.
So they're not really
into adventure stuff.
But the editor wanted
to give me a chance
to shoot some
adventure for them.
And I suggested a
different number of things,
and they decided to go
with the ice climbing
at night using big
studio flashes.
And this is-- yup.
No.
There we go.
So this is what my assistant was
supposed to be carrying for me.
And it turned out that
there was no assistant
because one of the models
dropped out and had
to be replaced by my assistant.
So I had to carry all
that garbage myself.
And I'll kind of give
you an idea of my roles
there, because I have
the climbing stuff,
I have my axes and my crampons
so that I can climb myself.
I have the ice screws that I
actually gave to the athletes.
I have all the stuff here
to ascend the fixed line.
And here I'm not
showing the ropes.
And then I have the
tripod for the camera,
and I have the tripods
for the lights.
And I have the lights,
and I have the modifiers,
and I have the flashes, and
the cameras, and the lenses.
So you can see, you have to have
many different roles at once.
And it was extremely
challenging,
because as you may be aware
of this is a terrible winter.
We had very little snow
and we have even less ice.
And then what little
snow we have usually
is very avalanche prone.
So this was shot in Cogne in
Italy near Gran Pardiso Park.
And it was very, very
challenging to find a route
that had enough
ice to be climbable
and that wasn't
threatened by avalanches.
So when I'm kind of managing
to align everything and have
good weather.
And this is Jen
Olson from Canada
looking at half of the climb.
So that's the first
picture that I got.
And here, it's
actually not night yet.
It's kind of evening.
There's still some light.
So I'm balancing ambient
light with-- you can't really
see because this is
pretty poor quality,
but it's actually
warmer in here.
And that's because I
have a light right there
that's shooting and kind
of lighting the ice.
And ice, of course,
is really interesting
because it's very
translucent and it
can give very cool effects.
And that's really what
I was looking for.
And so here, the
climber Aurelien
is almost at the end of
the first pitch, which
is like five meters above him.
And afterwards Jen
and myself joined him.
And I started
getting the pictures
that I was looking for.
And here, I was supposed
to have an assistant hold
the line somewhere.
And so I had no assistant.
And Aurelien was busy belaying
and she was busy climbing.
So I was one hand shooting
and in the other hand holding
the line, which is actually
something like five kilos.
So it was challenging, but in
the end it works out sometimes.
And here, what I'm
not too happy about
is that this is very frontal.
So the light is coming
from the same place
as the camera, which
is usually something
you're trying to avoid.
But in this case, you
couldn't really avoid it.
And you can still get
an effect of the ice.
And so they finished
climbing and I came down.
And here I used the
flash to illuminate
the entire waterfall,
but not enough
that you would drown
out the headlamp beam.
And kind of trying to balance
the headlamp that they're
using so that you can
see that it's night
and that they're actually
using headlamps but still see
the waterfall.
And then they started climbing
it again the second time.
And this is when it's key to
have models that are actually
athletes that love
what they're doing
and that are not
complaining about you asking
them to just go back up please.
And those are the pictures
that I came to shoot.
So ideally, what
I'd planned for was
to have the assistant on a
fixed line top right shoot in
and holding the light so that
it would go down on the climber.
But that was impossible, so
I actually left the light
on the tripod at
the bottom and I
used it to illuminate
the entire waterfall.
But to be a lot weaker
than the headlamp beam,
so that you could really have
this island of light idea.
But if you're shooting
that without the studio
strobe at the bottom, then
you're not seeing anything.
You're just seeing a blob of
white, which is the headlamp.
And that's another
one variation.
And here again, you're also
trying to go for a story.
You're also trying
to tell a story
and, again, you can't really
see but she's actually smiling.
If you see the image
in print, she's smiling
and you have the headline
beam that's looking up
and you have the ice axe.
And you can see, what
I'm hoping that people
can see in her eyes is that
yeah, climbing at night, ice,
this is cool.
And this is actually
what she was thinking.
So all good.
And this is the feature
last picture that I shot.
And sometimes you go
for black and white
because it looks better.
And again, this is all
about the story and all
about the light, the light
going through the ice.
And hopefully those images will
appear in "Sports Illustrated"
soon.
There we go.
So now we have a little
bit of time left.
So I'm going to walk you through
some of my favorite images
rather than talk about
a specific shoot.
And then if we have
some time left,
which I doubt I can tell you
about shooting Patagonian
Expedition races.
OK.
There we go.
So that's a picture
I shot two years ago.
I went skiing to the
top of Mont Blanc,
though we did not actually
manage to go to the summit
because my climbing
partner and girlfriend got
altitude sickness.
But this is an image, that's
something I really strive for.
This is a very authentic image.
It was a real moment.
I mean, we were
really climbing there.
Nothing is staged,
nothing is set up.
And she did not even
notice that I was shooting.
She just kept on walking,
kept on climbing.
And that's something I'm
really looking for in all I do.
And of course sometimes
you have to compromise
because a client expects
you to get an image
and you have to ask people
to do stuff many times.
But as much as
possible, I'm trying
to really capture
authentic moments.
And this image works
because of the contrast
between the blue of the snow and
the cold world of early morning
in the mountains,
high mountains.
That's above 4,000
meters of attitude.
And the warmth of the valley,
the valley lines at the bottom,
and of the sunrise
that's coming up.
And that's an
example of when you
have to compromise a little bit.
Because this is
staged to an extent.
This was shot for
the Petzl catalog.
And they wanted to shoot some
crevasse rescue scenarios.
And of course to shoot
a crevasse rescue,
you have to have
somebody in a crevasse.
So I kind of asked.
This is Liv Sansoz who's
falling into the crevasse.
And she used to be the best
woman climber in the world
about 15 years ago.
And now she does all
sorts of crazy stuff.
Base jumping, steep skiing,
paragliding, mountaineering,
you name it.
And I asked her to just
please go into the crevasse.
And I was expecting it
to run or jump or try
to find a way to walk down.
But no, she just walked
until the corners collapsed
and she fell down.
So just had enough time to raise
my camera to my eye and capture
that.
What's sad about it is that the
picture was actually never used
by Petzl because it's
too negative for them.
I mean they used a
lot of the pictures
afterwards of us rescuing
her, but somebody
falling into a crevasse
is not something
they want to be associated with.
And this one.
So the picture that I shot two
minutes later of those guys
that you can kind of guess
here coming up so that they're
leading and I'm shooting
them from above.
I shot exactly the same
picture, except you
don't have the rope coming up.
And that was the cover of the
Patagonia catalog in the US.
But I like this one better
because that's my girlfriend.
And you can see how happy
she is climbing here.
And here is an example of
many, many times I go out
and I do a climb,
and I bother having
my big camera, big bulky
camera, on my harness,
fully accessible, and I don't
get a single good picture.
That happens all the time.
But sometimes it pays
off to have it available,
to have it really ready.
And that was one of those cases.
So we had climbed on that day
from the Grands Montets station
here.
We had climbed
that entire ridge.
And we actually bivied like
half an hour later very close
to here and then
the next morning we
went to the summit
of Aiguille Verte.
And I had shot some
pictures on that day
because I felt bad about
not shooting any pictures,
but that was basically
the only reason.
And they were really,
really bad pictures.
And then at some point, I
had just finished climbing
and I was belaying and
everything lined up perfectly.
The clouds, the light, the
ridge, the faces, everything.
And because I had a
camera right there,
I was able to take the picture.
If it had been in the backpack,
this picture wouldn't exist.
So sometimes it's size,
it's always bothersome,
but sometimes it's worth it.
So this is a photo that
was taken on assignment
for the German brand VAUDE
for their winter collection.
And VAUDE, they have two
different kinds of assignments.
They have the ones where they
know they need specific images
and they hire somebody to
shoot the specific images.
And then they have the
ones that they give to me,
which I'm really happy about.
And that's, here's
some gear, here's
some money to pay some models,
and please go and bring
us back cool images.
And it's up to me to find
the right conditions,
and to find the right climb,
and to find the models
and to find everything.
And this is all about
serendipity to an extent,
because this image I had
no idea would exist up
until about five seconds
before I shot it.
But it's also very challenging
because especially for clothing
brands, when you're
shooting for them, usually
they have some crazy
schedules because they
get the samples for
the winter collection.
For instance, in
the case of VAUDE,
they get the samples
on September 20th
and they need the workbook to
go to print on September 30th.
So you have 10 days
in late September
to shoot the winter collection.
And usually mountains
in September
do not look like winter.
So in that case, we were lucky
and we got a storm before.
If you kind of forget
about the very dry glacier
in the background, you
could believe it's winter.
We had to do the same the
other way around in early April
last year, which was a very,
very snowy year, shooting
the summer collection.
And then you had people
skiing in deep powder
in Vallee Blanche in the
background, which is not
something you
usually do in August.
So it's also my job to make it
look to use tricks to an extent
to try and convey the right
message about the picture
that the client wants.
And in this case, we got
super lucky with the weather
as well, because
what happened here
is that the clouds that were
starting to roll in just
started diffusing the
sunlight a little bit,
and that's what gives
you the super soft light.
And it is actually reflected
in freshly fallen snow.
So this is like having the
world's biggest soft box just
lighting your subject.
And this is not
something-- I mean
if I was trying to replicate
this, it would take a crane,
basically holding some studio
lights just above the frame.
AUDIENCE: Question.
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you
photoshop a lot?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: No.
I do very, very
little photoshopping.
So that's, of course, a question
that comes back all the time.
And I do.
My post-processing is part
of my image creation process.
So I will tune up the colors and
the contrast and all of that.
But as I was saying
earlier about authenticity,
I always try to not cheat.
And of course, it's a
very personal decision.
And there's a line that
I try not to cross.
Basically, it's just out of
respect to myself, really.
But no.
I could show you the
original and of course it
looks a bit more dull, but
it's basically the same image.
AUDIENCE: How about HDR?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: I don't.
I don't.
I used to use HDR too, because
sometimes in the mountains
you have very high
contrast, it seems.
With modern sensors and
with modern software,
you don't need to anymore.
With especially the Nikon
D800, which this was shot with,
has such an insane
dynamic range.
And with light from
the foreground,
you can recover so much
highlight and so much
shadow that you don't
need to use HDR anymore.
And I'll start moving
a little bit faster.
So this is one of my
very favorite images
and one that I seem to be
almost alone in really liking.
it's very subtle and it takes
looking at it for quite a
while before you start
appreciating it, I think.
And also it needs
to be printed well.
And I'm sorry to say this
is not the case here.
But anyway, one of the
themes of my photography
often is trying to communicate
what I feel when I climb.
And that's the reason
I started shooting
while I was climbing while
I was in the mountains.
And one of the things that
I feel very, very often
is humility in the mountains.
Because you can think
you're the best climber,
you can think that you
can climb whatever.
And then you will
have a day where
you will be reminded
that you are nothing.
And that's something I'm trying
to communicate sometimes.
And here, having
this looming mountain
in the mist that without
even trying just completely
overpowers the
tiny human figure.
I don't know, it
really talks to me.
And this is actually Ama
Dablam that's in Nepal.
And this picture
that's coming up.
So this picture is
straight out of camera.
I have done nothing to it.
The only thing is that
it was slightly dark
because my settings
were not quite right,
so I just brightened
it a bit and that's it.
And people do not believe me.
I had even people tell me
that they could see artifacts
from the CGI that I had used.
But this is high altitude light
with crazy snow conditions
that you can find in the Andes.
That's at 6,300
meters in altitude.
And you get these kind of snow
footings and snow mushrooms
in the Andes,
especially in Peru.
And this is by far my
bestselling picture.
I shot that in 2009 and I've
sold more prints of it then
all of my other images combined.
AUDIENCE: What's the
shutter speed here?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: What's that?
AUDIENCE: What's the
shutter speed here?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE:
I have no idea.
This is shot at F8, because
I will shoot at F8 until--
unless I have--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE:
No, no, no, no, no.
I was coming down from the
summit of the mountain.
We had planned another route
and I was at 6,000 meters
and I was completely wasted.
But I saw that
and I had to stop.
I don't think the rope even
tightened because I always
try to not bother the
people that I'm roped up
with so I usually can
even while walking
get the camera in and out.
But this is F8, ISO-2, 200
I'm guessing, because that's
the base ISO the
camera was shooting.
And whatever the
shutter speed is.
My guess is around 250.
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
long exposure.
ALEXANDRE BUISSE:
No, no, no, no.
I think it's just because
it's a poor quality projector.
I'm sorry.
But no, this is a
fast shutter speed.
All right, quickly now.
So this picture, this is shot
inside a crevasse in Mer de
Glace.
And I was complaining
earlier on the other ice
climbing shoot about
not having an assistant.
Shit, I didn't even have
somebody to belay her,
so I was actually belaying
and shooting at the same time.
And of course I'm
shooting wide angle.
So I'm actually maybe 30, 40
centimeters from her crampons.
So I'm really hoping
that she doesn't fall.
And of course, this is also
a very challenging lighting
situation because the inside of
the crevasse is very, very dark
and the outside is
comparatively extremely bright.
So here I had to make a decision
to let completely go details
in the highlights at
the top so that I could
get all the
interesting stuff that
was going on with the
ice at the bottom.
And I think this one I
really like for one reason.
It's because it really
shows, and here it's
a little bit too dark but
you can kind of guess.
When you're ice climbing, what
you're actually standing on
is usually half percent
metal, sometimes less,
that's inside the ice on two
front points, and sometimes
one front point.
And here we can really see it.
And that's something
that often you can't.
And that's enough.
You know, it works.
Ice works.
But when you actually see
it, it makes you think a bit.
Yeah, another image
I like in Verdon.
Just playing with
silhouettes and trying
to have people build a
story around the image
and work themselves.
And that's the big difference
between video and photos.
In video usually you
have to be a bit more
explicit, whereas with photos,
with still photography,
you have to let people
guess and let people
build an entire back story,
and maybe front story even,
about what's going on.
And so here you have some
people highlining and some guy
base-jumping doing a back flip,
and some guy taking picture
and it's sunset.
You can't ask him
why, but not-- I
have another one
that's even more why.
This is slightly new
for me, I started
shooting from my paraglider.
When I discovered that I
could actually do that,
that was amazing.
And this in Annecy.
This one I just love
because of the light.
And it's funny because it
was actually a photo shoot.
This guy with the yellow wing
is a professional photographer
and a good friend of mine.
He's called Tristan
Shu, and he's
shooting the
designer of the wings
that both Tristan and myself
are flying in this picture.
And this guy was doing
crazy acrobatics.
And Tristan was shooting him.
And sometimes,
yeah, sometimes it
works because it
just looks cool.
So this is another
authentic moment on The Nose
that I kept in coming
down in a big storm.
And here the story
is very obvious.
It's cold, it's wet, and you
really don't want to be there,
but you have to keep
on going and keep on,
well, descending in that case.
And this is often the
case that everybody
can shoot when the
weather is good
and everything is going well.
But if you keep shooting
when things really go bad,
and people really
don't want to be there,
then that's when you get
the good stories sometimes.
And the less you want to
shoot, usually, the more
you should be shooting.
But of course I always, usually
when things go bad enough,
there's a point where I have
to put the camera away and just
focus on the climbing or just
focus on getting out of there,
go into survival mode sometimes.
AUDIENCE: Is your
camera waterproof?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: It
has proven to be so far.
I mean pro cameras can
take a lot of abuse.
But except for the D4,
and that would be the one
DXL Canon, which
are specifically
built to be waterproof,
that I still
wouldn't throw in the
ocean or anything.
But the other ones, will
usually withstand abuse,
but sometimes they just won't.
You can't really know why.
And I had some
issues with the lens.
Actually, pro lenses are
supposed to be water proof.
I had some issues with fogging
inside and stuff going in.
But cameras are tools, and
I'd rather destroy my camera.
I will tell my insurance
company that I'd rather
destroy my camera
and get the image
than not get the image because
I was worried about my gear.
And this is also,
I think, important.
That's actually after the climb.
And that's a
direction I'm trying
to go more and more in
finding a human connection
and not just showing the really
cool move in a crazy landscape
but also showing,
again, everything that
goes into the climb and what
it takes to do the climb.
And that was after a failure,
a big failure on The Nose.
And that's another case of a
picture that's just plain cool.
Because this guy
doesn't have any ropes,
so he's free soloing.
Yeah, so, it's just
about being there
and shooting the crazy guys.
OK, I'll start
speeding up a bit.
This is on Aiguille du Midi.
And it's a very
suggestive image.
And it was a snapshot.
I shot that because I just
saw the mountain looking cool.
And I realized when
I came back home
that these guys looking up,
if you have a bit more detail,
it actually looks even better.
And that makes image.
And sometimes you just
have to be a bit lucky.
Another image that was shortly
before the guy descending,
descending from
The Nose super wet.
So it was before we got wet.
And so here, the
story, I think--
the way that he's
leaning out is what
makes the image work
for me, because he's
looking at his leader
and thinking hurry up,
let's get the hell out of here.
And this image is coming up.
Yeah.
So again, you have to
build stories sometimes.
You have to let
people build stories.
And here I was
shooting highlining,
and this is the guy who was free
falling earlier, Mich Kemeter.
And then they started
putting a hammock on
and I was like
yeah, sure, why not.
And he started relaxing on it.
And then Armin came in and
started playing didgeridoo.
And I was like yeah,
OK, do your thing.
OK.
Very, very quickly,
which is not going
to work because this thing
takes 15 seconds to-- OK,
I was going to tell you about
shooting adventure racing
in Patagonia, which I've
done two years in a row.
And the race doesn't
exist anymore
now because it's really,
really, really crazy
to shoot down there.
But I think maybe we should
keep some time for questions.
I'll go through them
very quickly then.
This is a rescue exercise.
And the starts by night, so
that was the first year in 2012.
And this is a six
to eight days race.
They do 600 kilometers
in complete wilderness
and it's a wonder
that nobody died yet.
And then kayaking.
And of course penguins
because penguins.
And there we go.
And they're actually running.
This is 36 hours into
it and they're running.
And what I had to do
was to run with them.
That's the only way to get the
really good pictures, to get
better pictures than just
staying at checkpoints,
is to race with them.
And the reality of Patagonia
is that once you start hiking
in with them, you
kind of have to finish
that section with them.
So I ended up, in that
case, walking 100 kilometers
in 30 hours with them in
complete wilderness, no choice,
no nothing, Which
was very interesting.
So yeah.
And then the orienteering is
the big, big problem there.
That's how many
teams end up losing,
because the maps are terrible
and there are no landmarks
usually to orient against.
Very wild terrain.
Crossed that river
about 25 times maybe.
And this is the kind of images
that you cannot get if you are
not in with them and if
they don't trust you.
And that was after
24 hours of sharing
the suffering with them.
They let me take the picture.
Because you really want
to get to a checkpoint,
they're all smiles.
Because they have like 10
checkpoints in the entire race,
so they can change personae
when they get there.
Whereas that is what
this race is about.
It's about the
suffering and it's
about the pushing
yourself through.
And that's another one.
I don't know you can
really see his face,
but he didn't look at me.
And this is Patagonia,
so it looks super good.
Some cool landscapes.
So this is not, by far,
the worst case of it.
But that's, yeah.
And those guys will keep
on walking with that stuff.
It's crazy.
And then, yeah, suffering.
And that's Mark's
face when he was
told that they had finished.
It's amazing, it's
an eight days race
and those guys finished
with 14 minutes to spare.
So if they had been 14
minutes more, 15 minutes more,
they would have
been disqualified.
That's pretty crazy.
But they couldn't walk for
like a week afterwards.
And then I tried to
go climbing for myself
and that did not-- yeah.
So did a bivi and
then the next day
I had to come down because
150 kilometers an hour winds.
That's Patagonia for you.
Then I came back
last year again.
Same thing, same deal.
Just keep moving a bit.
Shooting at night,
that's the beginning.
And then last year,
within 24 hours,
all but three teams
had dropped out.
There were, I think,
14 teams starting.
Within 24 hours,
11 had dropped out.
That's how tough it is.
And yeah, this picture
is funny because it's
the only picture-- this
one-- I've actually
sold of that race.
And, you know.
Yeah.
It's a bit depressing sometimes.
And here I am crossing
the Hielo Continental
Sur, which is a
crazy ass glacier.
And here trying to
be a photographer,
trying to have graphic elements
and showing how huge it is.
They told us in
the briefing it's
going to be 11
kilometers crossed
in two hours, no crevasses.
And we walked 29 kilometers and
some of the biggest crevasses
that I've ever seen.
And those guys,
most of those guys
had never worn crampons before.
It was just, none of
them have ice screws.
It was just ridiculous.
So this is, again, trying to
be into the theme of we humans
are very small things.
That we're trying to find a
crossing, having some fun.
That was some of the
teams that dropped out
that we walked back with them.
Yeah, because we already
did 29 kilometers
and then slept, and then
walked back 29 kilometers
the other way.
So we had a bit more time.
So we just had some fun.
And those guys are two
fellow photographers,
and I'm going to Greenland
with this guy soon.
And Chris had gotten
really badly burned
after a small accident
with a jet [INAUDIBLE].
And he still had to walk out.
Even if you get badly injured,
you still have to walk out.
I mean if it's life
threatening, maybe
the Navy will come and
get you by helicopter.
If not you walk.
And he had something like
14 hours walk on his really,
really badly injured foot.
Yeah.
Kayaking, kayaking.
AUDIENCE: So why did
they all drop out?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: Too
late, usually too slow.
AUDIENCE: So they're at
the checkpoint [INAUDIBLE]?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: Yeah,
there are checkpoints
and they have time barriers.
And yes, getting into the
water to try and get the shot.
This guy.
And then trying to make
the most of my time there,
and this guy was a big ranch
owner, some gaucho pictures.
Whatever works.
And then the finish line
you kind of have to get.
And it's interesting because
then you get the emotion.
And that's something I'm
always looking for my pictures.
And I'm getting
very [INAUDIBLE].
Went climbing afterwards.
Had some fun.
Took some bad
images for clients.
That's for Petzl.
They want to take the headlamps,
so we shot the headlamps.
There you go.
And more headlamps.
You can't really see, that's
Cerro Torre in the background.
And we tried to go climbing.
Yeah, so that's kind
of like a sunrise.
We tried to go climbing a
rock route below Cerro Torre.
And it was 11 hours approach,
and we bailed after 10 meters
because it was too hard.
I was climbing.
We tried again another
time and then got
that picture, which is also
on the cover of the book.
And same thing, I
was actually climbing
when I took that but I had
the camera there, accessible.
And that was at the
very end of the day
when I really wanted
to go back to the tent
and sleep and not have
to abseil yet again.
But didn't completely turn down
the camera and the camera brain
and got that, which I
think works really well.
And sometimes you have to
take really bad pictures
for clients.
And I was charging the
headlamp with that.
And that's it.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I actually
just want to [INAUDIBLE]?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: Right.
AUDIENCE: Can you
repeat the question?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: Yeah sure.
So the question is basically
what are the economics of it.
And whether I can make a
good living at it or not.
It's a very complex question
to answer because there
is no business plan
for photographers.
There's no single
way of getting money.
So I get money from a
lot of different sources.
One of them is assignments
where people pay me upfront
and then I bring
back the pictures.
One way is spec shoots.
So I go out on my
own time, I shoot,
and then I send the pictures
afterwards to the clients,
and usually to Patagonia and
Black Diamond and whatnot.
And then they say yeah, yeah,
we like that, we can now buy it.
The Eiger was like that.
I paid my own money, and then
I sold the picture afterwards
to the sponsors
and to magazines.
And then I also
do fine art prints
which brings me a
fair amount of money.
And being a photographer right
now is very, very challenging.
What saves me is that not
that many people climb and not
that many people
do mountaineering.
There are lots of
climbers who shoot
and lots of photographers
who climb a bit,
but not many people who do both
well enough that people will
actually pay you money to do it.
And I mean there are some, and
we are three just in Germany.
And there's of course
many more in Switzerland
and Germany and France.
But we are not that many.
So that's kind of what saves me.
And I'm making a
decent amount of money.
I'm not rich by any
stretch of the imagination,
but I can sustain the
lifestyle, and that's really
what I'm [INAUDIBLE]
at the moment.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you see your
pictures stolen somewhere
and what do you do about that?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: Right.
So the question is whether
my pictures were stolen
and yes, every single day.
They get stolen a lot.
They usually don't get stolen
too much by commercially.
So people end up making
too much money from them
that I wouldn't be seeing.
That happens, though.
I sometimes try
to go after them.
So if it's stuff like
Pinterest or Tumblr
or just Russian sites always
have those 25 crazy images
or 25 most clicked,
blah blah blah blah,
I don't even bother sending
DMCAs, because what can you do.
It has happened to
me a couple times
that people used
them commercially
and that I've managed to
get money out of it, usually
as an invoice up front.
But most of the time, I
shouldn't be saying this,
but most of the
time I'm bluffing.
I'm saying I'm going to
explore my legal options is
the wording I use.
But my legal options,
if the guy is in Russia
or is in South
America is nothing.
So when it happens,
the few times
where I've managed
to actually get
money for pictures
that have been stolen
was people I had
talked to already
who had asked me for
quotes, I had sent quotes,
and then they said
no thanks and then
I find the images used anyway.
And then I contact
them and say, oh yeah,
it was a mistake,
blah blah blah.
And then they've paid.
But that's very rare.
I don't lose money, it's just
money that I'm not earning.
So I try not to spend too
much time thinking about it.
But yeah, it's a reality of how
the Internet works, basically.
And I use, often, reverse
searches with Google Images
to find uses.
So whoever's involved
with that, thanks.
Sorry.
Yeah, go for it.
AUDIENCE: How many
more images do you
take when you get intentionally
are good images versus those
you find [INAUDIBLE]?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: Right.
So the question is about
ratio of good to bad images.
It really varies.
On a typical shoot,
I will shoot maybe,
I don't know, 1,000
pictures in a day.
And of those I will try to
take no more than 10 to 15.
And that's actually
a pretty high number.
I will usually narrow that down
even more to three or four.
And self editing is one
of the hardest bits.
But I wouldn't be able
to put a definite figure
to tell you it's 2% or it's 10%.
All I can tell you
is that for me,
as for every single
photographer,
even Ansel Adams
and Robert Doisneau,
and whoever your
photo hero is has
tons of garbage in their files.
But the trick is to just
never show it to anybody.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE:
Especially with climbing,
it's different than
shooting in a studio,
because you can
only plan so much.
Like I made very advanced plans
for the ice climbing shoot
by night thing,
and then everything
fell out right
away, pretty much.
So I had to improvise.
Usually when I make
plans, I do get the image
that I had planned hopefully.
And then I'll try to improvise.
So I don't think there's
a very big difference.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned a few photos
that you sold a
lot of prints of.
How do you sell the prints?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE:
So the way I sell
prints is the fine art world
is very weird in that value
is completely disconnected
from the value
of the physical
object of the print.
So if I was selling a print
at EUR 50, people would think,
oh this print is worth EUR 50.
If I sell the print like I
do now, I'd start at EUR 500
for A3, people will
automatically think,
oh this must be a
really good print.
And of course, if
you're [INAUDIBLE],
and you start pricing
your stuff EUR 50 million,
people think, oh that's
because he's an amazing artist.
Even though the print
actually cost me the same
as if I was selling it EUR 50.
So I made a conscious
decision to position myself
in the very high
end simply because I
guess I could get the
same kind of revenue
if I was selling
10 images of EUR 50
as if I was selling one
at 500, give or take.
But it takes me a lot less
time and a lot less energy
to be dealing with images
that are on the high end.
So the way, concretely,
how it works,
it's just I have a page that's
called prints on my website
and on it I say
email me for details,
and then I get back
to them with prices.
And usually 98
percent of the people
don't even reply
because it's too high
and that's just the way it is.
But then the 2% that reply
are the one that I actually
make money from.
But that's a very small
part of my income.
I wouldn't be able to
live off fine art prints.
AUDIENCE: Do you
outsource the printing?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: Yeah.
Well outsource in that I
do a lot of very big prints
because usually when
people don't bold
cut your figure [INAUDIBLE]
they actually want
2 meters wide, which is going
to be EUR 2,000 or something.
And then printers for
that kind of sizes
are very, very expensive, and
I don't have the skills as well
to make a really good print.
So I use PIKTO, as do many,
many French professional
photographers, which is a
professional lab in Paris that
prints for museums and
prints for exhibitions.
So I know that the
service is really top.
AUDIENCE: So you don't
work with agencies at all?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: No.
So stock agencies, no.
I Well, technically yes.
But the contract has almost run
out and I will not renew it.
And I stopped submitting
stuff there ages ago.
I do work with
price agencies when
I get pictures like
the free soloing ones,
I had them run into
many newspapers
through a press agency, because
I don't have the contacts.
But stock agencies,
it's a volume game.
And usually the stuff that sells
is the vain, generic stuff.
And I try not to
shoot generic images.
So stock is a dead
end for most people.
I mean, I know some
people who make
a very good living from stock.
But it's a full time job.
It's soul sucking,
really, because you
have to spend a lot of time
keywording and shooting
bland stuff.
It really is a full time job
and I'm not interested in that.
And I don't even shoot
the right stuff anyways.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you say something
about your decision process
to switch careers?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: Right.
I hated computer science.
No.
So I come from the
same school as Benoit,
which is [INAUDIBLE] in France.
And I started the
Ph.D. Well I really
hope that some people will
not watch that recording.
But I started my
PhD and was starting
not to like the stuff
I was studying anymore.
And I basically
stopped caring about
whether my proofs
were valid or not.
But I finished the PhD.
And I had the nicest,
kindest supervisor ever,
because he should have
kicked me out within a year.
But he kept on with me and
I'm very grateful for that.
But I basically told myself that
I'm going to finish the PhD.
And then I'm going to
try to do something else,
because I'm not happy.
And something else,
the only thing
I had a chance of making money
with when I finished my PhD
was actually photography.
So I just thought, I'm going to
be living in Germany for a year
and see if I can
make it work out.
And it turned out I could.
So the experiment
is ongoing and I'm
hoping that I won't come back
in five years asking for a job
here.
Yup.
AUDIENCE: But you said that
you finished with the school
in 2011 and in the same
year you published a book.
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: Yeah.
So I did not work very much
on my PhD is the short answer.
And that was actually
really key for me
was to be able to spend all
those three years of PhD,
really you should say I was a
semiprofessional photographer.
I was not taking
assignments, but I was really
building a network of clients
and I was spending time
on my website and spending time
on my marketing and writing
books.
And that allowed me to
jump into it by the way
and to really have
to network of clients
and to really have that
name recognition when
I had to rely on photography
solely to pay my rent.
Before that, I had
three years where
my rent was paid by my PhD.
So yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So when you
go on an assignment
and the conditions aren't right
or you feel like you're not
taking good photos, how
do you balance the stress
that you need to go
back to your employer?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE:
I mean, they trust
you to find ways
to make it work.
Usually the clients,
at least the clients
I have at the moment
who are outdoor clients,
so they are climbers
and skiers themselves,
so they know that the conditions
sometimes aren't right.
But it's my job to get
them the images back.
And usually I try my best and I
always something to bring back.
And there was one situation, one
case, the Petzl shoot actually.
It was s two day shoot
and on the first day
I brought back some
images that he wanted,
but it turned out that it
wouldn't work with the layout
that they had because
in the catalogue
they needed very narrow images.
And none of them would work.
And I was kind of in the brief,
so it was technically my fault.
So I just did a re-shoot
a couple of days later
and I paid the models myself.
So whatever it takes.
My job is to make
the client happy.
They're trusting
me to bring them
back the images
and my livelihood
depends on not
disappointing them.
But it's extremely stressful.
And for instance, the
"Sports Illustrated" shoot
was an absolute nightmare
in terms of logistics.
And I did not sleep
for like a week
before that actually
happened because I was too
stressed about all the details,
everything that could go wrong.
But usually, mountains
are good looking,
you're shooting
good looking people.
You can bring back images.
AUDIENCE: And you mentioned
that most of your income
doesn't come from print.
Is it from the stipends?
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: Yeah, I
would say it's about 50/50.
I don't have the
figures, but it's
50% assignments and 50% spec
shoots that I sell afterwards.
And then I have a lot
of clients completely
unrelated to the outdoors.
Sometimes, actually,
quite a lot of bankers,
because mountaineering
images speak to them.
You know, the whole challenging
yourself and reaching summits
and being in a rope
team, blah blah blah.
So they love that stuff.
And I get inquiries
very often from people
who want to buy images
and who are into finance,
or into whatever.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: Right.
So the question is
about how to carry
the camera while I'm climbing.
And it is one of the questions
I'm asked most frequently.
There is no good solution
that's the basic of it.
I use two different systems.
One of them is called
a ThinkTank Skin,
and it is a belt with
pouches that you can adjust,
small bags that you can compress
when they're not in use.
It's very modular.
So you can just have
the one for the lights,
and the camera, and lenses.
And I don't use backpacks
and I don't use chest straps,
because they hide my feet.
And when I'm skiing or
climbing, I have to see my feet.
And that stuff, I can kind
of rotate them out of the way
and can keep my balance
more or less right.
The other system I use is from
a company called Peak Design.
It's the Capture Camera Clip.
And it's a small clamp
that you put on a harness
or on a backpack,
and then you can just
take the camera in or out.
And both systems do not
protect the camera at all,
so I send my lens,
my wide angle lens,
to Nikon every six months
because the front element is
shattered.
But as I was saying
earlier, it's a tool.
But yeah.
It's a big, bulky thing.
And it's heavy, it's fragile,
and you're doing crazy stuff.
And there's no good solution.
There's no great solution.
There are OK solutions
to carry a camera.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
ALEXANDRE BUISSE: Yeah, sure.
Well thanks very much.
And then I'm going to be here
for the evening, I guess,
if you guys want to chat
or take a look at the book.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]